Justin Jarrett
We always have an argument about coal or solar or two degrees warmer or not,
whether it's true science or no. There's a bigger story out there.
And when you look at what agriculture is trying to do, we have to survive in
the environment as a business.
We're not in an office block.
We have to actually go out there and produce a product in a paddock under those conditions.
So I think agriculture has changed significantly
over time. What I would say to people is: what have you done as an individual?
It's about everyone doing their bit.
And I often get frustrated when I sit around a table with all my mates and
we're having a few reds, particularly when I'm in Sydney, and they say: this is not
happening; that's not happening.
I ask them: what have you done about buying a product that actually supports a
change in the system?
And they look at you and they blame a politician for something they can change themselves.
And that's why agriculture is so exciting, because we have to change.
If you don't, you go broke.